As an actor, having someone who looks exactly
like you can give you a big advantage.
While some duos, like the Olsen twins or Dylan
and Cole Sprouse, have made it a part of their
brand, here are some stars that you may not
have realized have an identical twin.
In 2009, Jill Hennessy spoke with Contact
Music about the burdens her identical twin
Jacqueline often faces, saying,
"She gets stalked by people who don't believe
she's my twin.
She'll very kindly say, 'I'm Jack, her sister,'
and they'll think she's lying.
They think it's really Jill Hennessy just
being really bitchy!"
While Jacqueline and her sister Jill have
each carved out separate accomplished careers
on their own — the former has a Ph.D. in
French literature, is a journalist and TV
host, and the latter was Claire Kincaid on
"Law & Order" and the titular character on
"Crossing Jordan" — the sisters have collaborated
several times in film and music.
They once had a duo called Jack and Jill,
were buskers in Toronto's subways, and still
sing together to this day.
The pair made their film debut together, playing
twin escorts in David Cronenberg's 1988 drama
"Dead Ringers."
In the 1996 "Law & Order" episode "Corpus
Delicti", Jacqueline literally stood in for
her sister for courtroom scenes while Jill
was off shooting a crossover episode with
"Homicide: Life on the Street."
When Jill wrote and directed 2000's "The Acting
Class," she was sure to include her older
sister in the roll call.
While Rami Malek hit the big time as Elliot
on TV's "Mr. Robot," and as Freddie Mercury
in the biopic "Bohemian Rhapsody," his identical
twin brother Sami has been spending his time
handing out grades as a teacher in Los Angeles.
Sami currently teaches English as a Second
Language at a middle school.
The only time Sami gets into character and
costume is to protest and demand changes for
schools.
He's very passionate about his vocation, and
is known to fight for both teachers and students
alike.
The closest Sami gets to the limelight is
to celebrate his brother's success, particularly
at the 2019 Academy Awards when Rami took
home the Best Actor award, saying in a red
carpet interview,
"My boy had it in the bag.
He killed it."
Rami has also joked that his success in film
and TV is likely to give his brother a boost
in his romantic life.
During an appearance on "Jimmy Kimmel Live!"
Rami told a switcheroo story where he came
to Sami's aid when he needed to do a Greek
monologue for a class in order to graduate
from UCLA.
When Sami's teacher was floored by the performance,
Rami responded,
"Oh… it's just a hobby."
The first transgender person to be nominated
for an Emmy, Laverne Cox got her breakout
role as Sophia Burset, a charismatic inmate
in "Orange is the New Black."
When it came time to film flashback scenes
featuring Sophia before her transition, however,
it was easy to find the perfect fit: Laverne's
twin brother.
Going by the name M Lamar, the avant-garde
artist is an operatic countertenor and pianist
whose music is frequently blended with film,
sculpture, installation and performance.
The twins had a difficult time growing up
and being different in their hometown of Mobile,
Alabama.
They were constantly bullied at school, but
their mother Gloria impressed upon them the
importance of education, telling the local
paper in 2019 that she, quote, "groomed them
for success."
While Laverne is out and proud, Lamar takes
a more subdued approach, as he told World
of Wonder in 2016.
"What I do is not designed to cross over to
the mainstream.
That's not my goal.
I'm not looking for that sort of fame or recognition."
However, Lamar did indeed step into the mainstream
on one occasion, when he played the pre-transition
version of Sophia Burset in the season one
"Orange is the New Black" episode "Lesbian
Request Denied."
Cox originally wanted to play the role herself,
but she told the Huffington Post in 2013 that
the episode's director, Jodie Foster, quote,
"didn't think [she] looked masculine enough
to play a guy."
Harriet Norton told the Louisville Courier-Journal
in 1971 about her famous sister:
"We used to say we'd both be in the theater,
me on Broadway and her in the operating theater.
But she's the one who got into show business."
Norton's twin sister was none other than Ann
B. Davis, known for playing the lovable and
ever-dependable housekeeper Alice on "The
Brady Bunch."
Ann found early success on "The Bob Cummings
Show" in the role of Schultzy, which won her
back-to-back Emmy awards in 1958 and 1959.
After the second win, Harriet wired her sister
the message,
"One of us was bound to have twins."
Harriet was given the chance to join Ann in
a Schultzy "double" episode, but couldn't
handle the lines, so the idea was scrapped.
That probably explains why Harriet wasn't
enlisted to play Alice's identical cousin
"Sergeant Emma" on the "Brady Bunch" episode
of the same name, where Ann ended up taking
on both roles herself.
Regardless, the two maintained an unwavering
bond throughout their entire lives.
Ann died in 2014, at age 88.
She never married and is survived by Harriet,
who currently resides in Tucson, Arizona.
Bonar Bain never missed a chance to take a
playful swipe at his more famous brother,
Conrad Bain of TV's "Maude" and "Diff'rent
Strokes," telling the Ottawa Citizen,
"He's 20 minutes older than I am and he looks
every minute of it."
The two Bain boys were dedicated to their
local dramatic arts program in their teen
years, trading off lead roles in their school
plays.
When Conrad headed to New York to advance
his acting career, Bonar chose a different,
more stable path back in Edmonton, developing
a successful career in the airline, rental
car and parking businesses.
However, that didn't stop him from taking
an occasional part.
When the writers of "Maude" drummed up an
episode involving the escaped-convict twin
of Conrad's character Arthur, Conrad lamented,
"I knew we were in trouble.
The scriptwriters had my brother as a sex
maniac."
In the end, Conrad played both parts and Bonar,
quote, "only came in for two lines at the
end when he [got] caught, but everybody thought
it was him the whole time."
A similar experience took place on the "The
Van Drummonds" episode of "Strokes."
Conrad played their Dutch cousin Anna Van
Drummond, and in the scenes where Philip appeared
alongside her, Bonar acted as a stand-in.
Bonar went solo a few other times, most memorably
spoofing Conrad as alien double agent "Hank
Bain" on "SCTV," appearing in a sketch called
"Different Folks."
Back in the 1940s, Conrad was set to be an
extra in a Canadian war propaganda film, but
got sick right before the shoot.
Bonar stepped in for his brother, and remembered:
"The casting director took one look at me
and said, 'What difference does it make?'"
Bonar passed away in 2005, at age 82.
Conrad followed in 2013, at age 89.
Before Linda Hamilton was trying to escape
from "The Terminator," she was performing
in community children's theater back in Salisbury,
Maryland alongside her sister Leslie, who
was born six minutes after she was.
Linda recalled in 1987:
"We would be cast in the same role and work
alternate performances.
It was a real gimmick."
While Linda made the jump to Hollywood, Leslie
followed her own passion by becoming a nurse
and caretaker.
Leslie does have one credit to her name, however,
and it's in one of the greatest action films
of all time: she played a cyborg imitation
of Sarah Connor in "Terminator 2: Judgment
Day," and was paid a thousand dollars for
her time and effort.
Being on set not only gave Leslie a glimpse
of the Hollywood limelight, but also a taste
of the fun too, as she once even Arnold Schwarzenegger
himself into thinking she was Linda.
One film was more than enough for Leslie,
however.
After vowing to never return to the franchise,
Linda changed her tune and suited back up
as Sarah Connor in 2019's "Terminator: Dark
Fate."
Leslie passed away in 2020 at age 63.
When the writers for "Days of Our Lives" asked
their star Deidre Hall if there were any storylines
she'd like to pursue, she was quick to pitch
the idea of giving her character, Dr. Marlena
Evans, a twin sister.
Not long after, Deirdre's sister Andrea took
a break from her summer job as a special education
teacher to play Marlena's jealous twin Samantha.
The job spilled beyond the summer, and ended
up lasting several seasons.
The first time the pair acted together was
in 1977, in the Krofft brothers cult classic
show "Electra Woman and Dyna Girl," where
Andrea played Deirdre's clone.
Andrea returned to "Days of Our Lives" in
2000 when she showed up as Hattie Adams, a
woman who just so happens to look exactly
like Marlena.
The pandemic turned into a mixed blessing
for the twins, who got to spend over nine
weeks together for the first time since their
youth.
Andrea gushed,
"It's like find­ing your best friend again.
It's been grand.
[…] [P]aint­ing is so much fun, but we
just mostly laughed."
In 2007, Jon Heder told Elle magazine that
his relationship with twin Daniel is like
a marriage.
"My brother and I think alike, know everything
about one another, and when we get together,
we block everything else out.
Nothing exists in our world except for us."
The Heder boys were always artistic, and followed
their brother Doug to BYU to study animation.
Jon found everlasting fame playing the title
role in 2004's "Napoleon Dynamite," then went
on to star in such films as "Blades of Glory"
and "The Benchwarmers."
Daniel is a visual effects artist who has
worked on blockbuster films like "Alita: Battle
Angel" and "Guardians of the Galaxy."
He also worked as an animator on 2006's "Monster
House," where his brother Jon provided a voice
over.
The two have acted together in a few short
films, and Ashton Kutcher helped Daniel prank
Jon in a 2005 episode of "Punk'd."
Along with their older brother Doug, they
formed Greasy Entertainment and have several
projects in the works — including, of course,
some animated ones.
As for being twins outside of work?
Jon has admitted that they switched classrooms
for a day in sixth grade — but the scheme
backfired when Daniel took a pop quiz he obviously
wasn't prepared for.
Jon Heder wasn't the only twin to star in
"Napoleon Dynamite," as Efren Ramirez got
a vote of confidence as the titular hero's
best friend Pedro.
Efren and his identical twin Carlos were discovered
on the street by Robert Blake, who got them
roles in his series "Hell Town."
Carlos took a break from acting in 1991 and
joined the United States Air Force, but when
Efren's career skyrocketed, he returned to
the craft.
The two appeared together in "Potheads: The
Movie," as well as the high-octane action
movie "Crank" and its sequel, "Crank: High
Voltage."
They shared screen time and many good times
in real life, throwing famously raucous dual
birthday bashes.
Unfortunately, the story of the Ramirez brothers
doesn't have the happiest of endings.
The Ramirez twins had a falling out over Carlos
making public appearances as Efren... without
his brother's consent.
According to a 2013 TMZ report, Efren threatened
to sue his brother for 10 million dollars
in 2008, and they hadn't spoken since.
Carlos told TMZ at the time,
"I think it's safe to say the magnitude of
'Napoleon Dynamite' and everything that has
come along with it has ruined my relationship
with my twin."
As of present day, both Ramirez brothers are
still making appearances in films and TV series
— just not together.
If you've ever wondered what it's like to
have a celebrity doppelganger who's starring
in one of the most successful shows of the
1990s, firefighter Caroline Paul detailed
exactly how it feels in her 2015 book "Almost
Her: The Strange Dilemma of Being Nearly Famous."
"The possibility of an identical twin never
crossed anyone's mind.
It was easier to believe that the 'Baywatch'
star had decided to swaddle herself in a turnout
coat and helmet, grab that ax, and jump on
a fire engine for the day."
Caroline's slightly older twin sister is actress
Alexandra Paul, who made a splash on TV as
Stephanie Holden for 5 seasons of "Baywatch."
She's also made appearances in films like
"Christine," "8 Million Ways to Die," and
"Dragnet."
Caroline never joined the acting business
herself, but did work on "Christine" as Alexandra's
stand-in on set, confusing director John Carpenter
in the process.
Alexandra told the Ohio News-Journal in 1999
how deep her bond runs with Caroline:
"I'll always have her, even if everything
else goes badly.
It's like having your left arm or something.
She means everything to me."
Despite what you might think on first look,
Sidra Smith has something to say:
"I am not the lady from the Tyler Perry movie!"
It's an easy mistake to make — her identical
twin sister Tasha is indeed the lady from
the Tyler Perry movie, having starred in 2007's
"Why Did I Get Married?" and its 2010 sequel.
In a 2017 Instagram post, Sidra teased,
"I'm the oldest twin.
I always say that I came out first because
she KICKED me OUT so she could be in our mothers
belly ALONE for 2 minutes."
The sisters overcame a tough upbringing and
both left their hometown of Camden, New Jersey
for greener pastures.
While Tasha made appearances in films like
"Couples Retreat" and shows like "Empire,"
Sidra became a casting director.
Despite their difference in occupation, the
two always strive to help each other in their
endeavors, with Tasha telling NPR in 2008,
"My sister is my business partner, my twin.
She's an amazing producer, writer.
You know, we're just grinding and trying to
make my mother proud as well as God."
The two did appear on screen together once,
getting the opportunity to say a single word
between the two of them in the film "Twin
Sitters."
While they have confused many fans in public,
they also have fooled the technology of Apple,
proving that identical twins can pass for
the other when using iPhone's face activation
security feature.
Nicholas Brendon had dreams of playing for
the Dodgers, but an injury took him off the
baseball diamond and onto a TV set.
Nicholas found early success as Xander Harris
in "Buffy the Vampire Slayer," while his brother
Kelly took industry jobs behind the scenes
as a set decorator.
When Kelly finally decided to join his brother
in the limelight, he landed a role on "Buffy"
as a Xander double in the season five episode
"The Replacement".
The pair also appeared together for several
episodes of "Hollywood Squares" and the mind-bending
2013 horror film "Coherence."
Despite Kelly's later start, Nicholas has
always been happy to boost his brother in
any way he can.
In 1999, Nicholas told Teen People that the
duo have a very special relationship, saying,
"There's this unexplained twin phenomenon
that even we can't understand."
The two have so much in common, in fact, that
they've been known to spontaneously belt out
the same song at the exact same time, and
have even had similar recurring dreams.
Actress Lorraine Vélez is very close with
her slightly younger sister, but not too close:
she once told Latin Heat,
"My sister is part of my journey, but not
all of it.
I exist as an individual."
Lorraine's twin sister, Luna Lauren Vélez,
is also an actress, singer, and dancer.
The Vélez twins both attended the Alvin Ailey
Dance school, then studied acting at The Acting
Studio.
Lorraine headed to the West End of London
where she starred in musicals like "Miss Saigon,"
"Fame," and "Rent," but she later returned
to the States to pursue further creative endeavours.
At the same time, Luna was becoming a recognizable
face to audiences on TV shows such as "New
York Undercover," "Oz," "Ugly Betty," and
"Dexter."
The two have a single shared credit to their
names — the 2002 "Hitman" episode of "Law
& Order" — but never actually share the
screen during its runtime.
That doesn't mean the two don't spend time
together when they're off camera, however
— Luna consistently shares photos of the
pair together on her Instagram, especially
on #TwinTuesday.
Being identical was particularly rough going
on the Laurance brothers, who both decided
to become actors at the same time.
Matthew said to Entertainment Weekly,
"If you have to pick a business not to go
into with an identical twin, this is it.
We didn't talk for a long time."
Best known for cleaning teeth as David Silver's
dad Mel on "Beverly Hills, 90210," Matthew
was born four minutes later than his twin.
Elder brother Mitchell shared his twin’s
opinions on the entertainment business, saying,
"At times I hate the fact that Matthew's here.
We have moments of closeness and a lot of
times of conflict."
The two were able to get past their differences
and collaborated several times, including
for a pair of "Cop Rock" episodes and an appearance
on "The Commish."
On "Saturday Night Live," Matthew was a featured
player in Season 6, while Mitchell held various
roles, eventually becoming an associate director.
In the memorable "Outer Limits" episode "In
Another Life," Mitchell played a man trapped
in an alternate reality, surrounded by many
different versions of himself, which were
played by both he and Matthew.
When Mitchell decided it was time to leave
the soap opera "Santa Barbara" and move on
to "Reasonable Doubts," Matthew was there
to take his place.
The two have since moved away from Hollywood
and into the world of golf podcasting: Matthew
hosts the "Backspin Golf" radio show and podcast
for ESPN, while Mitchell is the Co-Host and
Co-Producer of "Talking GolfGetaways with
Mitch & Darin."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.